die zweite sache ist wie geht man dann
mit einem geld um
ich meine wir haben auf der einen seite
sicherlich leute die sagen das liegt
direkt alles zur seite wir haben auf der
anderen seite aber auch jede menge leute
die dann sagen ausgeben was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich es
geht euch gut wir haben uns ja jetzt
hier schon angeschlagene wochen nicht
mehr gesehen also ich glaube genau eine
woche ist mittlerweile an die dies nicht
mitbekommen haben ich war ja jetzt zwölf
tage in amerika also los angeles und las
vegas sein kann es vielleicht ein
bisschen wie urlaub beschreiben ich
wollte aber eigentlich auch videos
machen es war nur echt schwer weil das
internet in vielen hotels dort ist
einfach schlecht für manches internet
muss man sogar bezahlen und dann habe
ich mir einfach gesagt gut dann machst
du jetzt mal eine woche einfach mal
pause ich habe jetzt wieder ewig so was
nicht gemacht deswegen warum nicht jetzt
bin ich allerdings wieder da und habe
mir gedacht machst du heute mal diesen
topf will das wort gefällt mir nicht
aber ich in eine selbst trotzdem sucht
und zwar aus zwei gründen erst ist es
passt wirklich gerade glaube ich wieder
ganz gut und der zweite ist über dieses
thema so konkret hat glaube ich bis
jetzt noch niemand gesprochen der halt
mit youtube seite war sein geld verdient
und das kann ich eigentlich gar nicht
wirklich verstehen
deswegen mache ich das halt jetzt mal
als erstes alle die sich jetzt hiervon
erhoffen dass ich genau sagen wie viel
geld ich verdiene das werde ich
natürlich nicht tun also könnten direkt
eigentlich heute aushalten aber ich kann
mich trotzdem sagen es wird interessant
taufen hast du mich weiß ich immer noch
ein bisschen fertig aus gusterath doch
recht viel schlaf nachholen aber jetzt
wird hier los gelabert und zwar weil ich
einfach mal an ich habe mir keinerlei
stichpunkte gemacht im großen und ganzen
geht es um geld verdienen geld verdient
ist ja eigentlich was cooles werfer die
nicht gerne geld ich glaube das macht
jeder eigentlich je mehr desto besser
kann man glaube ich so sagen und das ist
ja auch kein geheimnis dass youtube
schon eine menge geld verdienen
natürlich muss man dafür auch erst mal
eine gewisse reichweite haben aber alles
so ab 3 400 tausend abonnenten verliehen
schon und ich gutes geld mit youtube
video natürlich gibt es da auch noch mal
differenzierungen die einen fall
mehr die einen verdienen weniger im
titel habe ich jetzt glaube ich
geschrieben wie es ist plötzlich viel
geld zu verdienen und das ist auch das
worum es heute eigentlich geht und zwar
ich habe ja auch jede menge freunde die
ebenfalls youtube videos machen und ich
kann jetzt eigentlich mal von meinen
erfahrungen berichten und zwar war ich
damals 17 jahre alt ungefähr oder
vielleicht sogar auf 16 jahre alt und
habe mit youtube videos gemacht ich habe
nicht mit irgendeinem nebenjob noch 400
euro im monat verdienen das heißt ich
hatte damals glaube ich 50 euro
taschengeld oder so was ich immer
bekommen habe von meinen eltern bin halt
zur schule gegangen und das war's also
ich habe mich auch gar nicht wirklich um
geld gekümmert das waren wir damals
überhaupt nicht wichtig und dann fängst
du an mit youtube-videos und plötzlich
hast du dann 50.000 abonnenten das ist
überhaupt nicht viel
klar trotzdem sind mit diesen 50.000
abonnenten wenn es gut läuft das kann
ich jetzt auch einfach mal so offen
sagen bestimmt 6 7 8 9 100 euro im monat
möglich und stellt euch mal vor wie es
ist er geht zur schule habt absolut kein
geld seit gerade mal 16 jahre alt und
plötzlich von einem auf den anderen
monat so war es damals bei mir habt ihr
einfach einen verdienst von 8 900 euro
das hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich für
die meisten erst mal mega cool und ich
meine es ist natürlich auch mehr cool
man darf man nicht vergessen man ist
extrem jung eigentlich für so viel geld
und die zweite sache ist wie geht man
dann mit dem geld um
ich meine wir haben auf der einen seite
sicherlich leute die sagen das liegt
direkt alles zur seite wir haben auf der
anderen seite aber auch jede menge leute
die dann sagen ausgegeben und damit
kommen wir dem titel vom video wie es
ist plötzlich viel geld zu verdienen
auch schon ein bisschen näher wobei ich
da auch ganz klar sagen muss viel geld
ist natürlich immer komisch definiere
ich meine ich verdiene in meiner lage
gerade sicherlich viel geld das kann man
so sagen aber es gibt natürlich
millionen von menschen die noch viel
viel mehr verdienen trotzdem bin ich
komplett alleine
ich habe keine familie oder sonstwas und
da ist es für die meisten youtuber
eigentlich für alle die halt so in
meiner größe sind extrem viel geld das
muss man halt auch so anerkennen und das
muss man vor allem zu schätzen wissen
also wie schon eben gesagt man muss das
zu schätzen wissen und das ist sehr sehr
schwer wenn man 16 17 jahre alt ist und
plötzlich über monate hinweg
viel geld verdient dann ist es schwer
mit der zeit das nicht als
selbstverständlich anzusehen man ist in
einer lage die hat vielleicht einer von
tausenden in diesen jungen jahren und
das ist halt wirklich das gefährliche
daran in meinem fall zum beispiel als
ich noch unter 18 war das natürlich
alles über die eltern ja das ist auch
sehr wichtig und ich hoffe darauf dass
alle eltern vernünftig damit umgehen ich
habe davon hat immer das bekommen was
ich haben wollte und es war für mich
echt mega cool hat plötzlich so viel
geld zur verfügung zu haben trotzdem wie
schon eben gesagt es bringt auch
sicherlich viele gefahren mit sich
es gibt beispiele wie zum beispiel die
lok ist ich glaube ich schon mit 14 oder
15 jahren ja plötzlich enorme reichweite
hatten womit halte auch geld in
verbindung gebracht wird und es gibt
genug fälle von youtube an die noch
unter 18 jahre alt sind mehrere
millionen user im monat machen und dass
dafür geld mit warum kommt ist halt kein
geheimnis deswegen ist es dann sehr sehr
wichtig dass sich die eltern darum
kümmern
sodann gibt es jetzt auch das
gegenbeispiel mann ist zum beispiel 18
jahre alt und explodiert von einem auf
den anderen monat auf youtube komplett
hat im einem monat vielleicht noch 200
euro damit verdient und im nächsten
monat schon 4000 euro keine ahnung sind
natürlich jetzt irgendwelche daher
gegriffenen summen aber wenn man mal
irgendwie ein placement um die ecke
kommt kann das halt sein
und der grund warum ich dieses video
jetzt im heute gemacht habe ich weiß
nicht ob ich das mitbekommen habe ich
habe mich da jetzt gestern nochmal zu
informiert weil ich hab gerade sehr sehr
wenig von youtube auf dem schirm
sozusagen irgendwie der youtuber miguel
pablo jetzt komplett durchgedreht und
hat irgendwas ich weiß nicht da ich habe
irgendwann video gesehen da halt gesagt
dass er absolut kein geld mehr hat
blablabla aus welchen gründen auch immer
ich will das auch gar nicht ins detail
gehen
wenn jetzt nur allein zum beispiel von
vielen die halt 18 jahre alt sind und
plötzlich extrem viel geld damit
verdienen aber noch gar nicht reif genug
sind um mit diesen summen überhaupt
umzugehen ich hoffe ihr könnt mir das
jetzt auch glauben und es auch
nachvollziehen
jetzt aus meiner situation das ist halt
wirklich sehr sehr gefährlich ist bei
dem es gerade erst aufgefallen dass wir
die ganze zeit herunter hing ist jetzt
auf jeden fall weg ich habe gar kein
wachstum in meiner wohnung deswegen
sieht das leider so aus egal ist halt so
ich bin gerade von rausgekommen
aber wir machen jetzt weiter und zwar
wollte ich noch ergänzen
es ist eine extrem große herausforderung
wenn man halt gerade mal 16 17 18 jahre
alt ist
hoffentlich reif genug zu sein um damit
umzugehen und das ist halt auch wie
schon so oft betont habe die große
gefahr daran dass man natürlich von
jetzt auf gleich praktisch von null auf
hundert in den meisten fällen ist es
halt so dass man nicht langsam da
reingerutscht sondern explodiert auf
youtube und dann von null auf hundert
extrem viel geld macht und das
gefährliche daran ist natürlich jetzt
kann so schnell wieder vorbei sein wie
es angefangen hat oder es gibt natürlich
auch fälle da ist es dann einen monat so
einem anderen monat so und dann
vielleicht wieder so und dann so also es
variiert und dann macht sich dann halt
gedanken etwas mache ich mir jetzt
gerade falsch trotzdem wenn man dann
plötzlich als youtube ziemlich weit oben
ist kann man wirklich extrem tief fallen
und wenn man damit nicht umzugehen weiß
oder das nicht klar für sich hat dann
passieren halt glaube ich sehr sehr
schnell
schlimme sachen mit einem selber so wie
es jetzt anscheinend bei miguel war oder
keine ahnung habe ich mir halt angeguckt
habe nicht nur wirklich schon krass was
das jetzt genau für hintergründen hat
oder was auch immer aber es gibt
natürlich auch noch eine menge weitere
beispiele die ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
nennen möchte vielleicht eine sache oder
einen fall den man auch sagen könnte
wenn ein team wie ich weiß nicht ob er
dennoch kennt aber der war ja auch
ziemlich populär und irgendwann hat sich
dann kaum noch jemand für den
interessiert und ich glaube da sind
dadurch dann auch einige blöde sachen
passiert bei ihm also man sollte so
etwas auch wirklich kritisch betrachten
ich meine es ist sehr sehr wichtig sich
dadurch auch dinge zu erfüllen ich
glaube wenn man irgendwelche wünsche hat
die vielleicht realistisch sind
plötzlich dann sollte man sich sowas
auch mal erfüllt das ist ganz wichtig
für einen selber ich meine ich habe hier
meine eigene wohnung so zu sagen ich
habe mein studium finanzieren und das
auto was eigentlich so mein traumauto
war und jetzt kann ich das halt fahren
so ja das weiß ich zu schätzen und das
ist wichtig trotzdem achtet auch darauf
dass ich jeden monat so viel wie möglich
bei seite lege ich habe zum beispiel
mehr so einen tagessatz gesetz dass ich
jeden tag nicht mehr als 20 euro
ausgeben möchte klar manchmal klappt es
nicht aber ich achte schon darauf das
ist meistens klappt was ich aber nur
jedem raten kann ist ja auch ganz klar
möglichst viel beiseitezulegen vor allem
an die leute die vielleicht gerade
hauptberuflich youtuber sind gar nicht
mal studieren oder
weil sie nicht man sie haben ja nicht
mal in den schulabschluss oder eine
ausbildung absolviert das ist
wahrscheinlich gerade mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit die zeit in eurem
leben in der er am meisten geld verdient
weil es wird ja auch nicht ewig gehen
vermutlich durch das internet ist halt
jedem und vor allem der generation die
damit aufgewachsen ist diese chance hat
möglich schon in jungen jahren extrem
viel geld machen sei es jetzt dadurch
dass man eine besondere persönlichkeit
hat gut unterhalten kann und sich dann
durch lang ist durchhaltevermögen er
plötzlich eine reichweite auf youtube
auf instagram brauch immer aufbaut und
dadurch halt eine menge geld verdient
oder es gibt ja auch jede menge andere
möglichkeiten wie bitcoins
online-marketing was auch immer egal ob
es jetzt in gutem licht steht es sind
die möglichkeiten da viel geld zu
verdienen in jungen jahren und das sind
nicht mehr nur die leute die möglichst
erfahren sind in hohen positionen sind
die halt dadurch viel geld verdienen ich
weiß ich habe jetzt irgendwie schon viel
zu viel geld gesagt trotzdem was ich am
ende zusammen fassen noch sagen kann es
war einfach meine meinung ihr könnt sehr
sehr gerne eure meinung dazu
mal und in die kommentare schreiben ich
werd mir einiges durchlesen und ich
hoffe ihr könnt verstehen warum ich
einfach mal dieses video gemacht habe es
ist sehr schön und man sollte diese
position zu schätzen wissen wer weiß wie
lange sowas geht aber es ist auch sehr
gefährlich und nicht zum beispiel wenn
ich mir halt verschiedene youtube-kanäle
anschaue und so die persönlichkeiten so
ein bisschen ja kennen lernen kann man
finde ich genau sehen welche person
damit umgehen kann und welche person
damit überhaupt nicht umgehen kann
und ja das ist halt einfach die sache
daran die dieses plötzlich so gefährlich
macht die einen sind reif genug dadurch
die anderen haben noch ihre eltern die
hoffentlich reif genug dafür sind und
alle anderen haben halt auf dauer ein
problem
und ja das war es mit diesem video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen und hat ihren
geschaut wenn ja gibt gerne doch nach
oben und wir sehen uns eventuell schon
morgen wieder abonniere ich vergessen
jetzt kommen wieder eine menge videos
und haut rein